(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> Jon: WELCOME BACK.
WELCOME BACK.
NOW THAT WE KNOW THAT
EVERYTHING WE HOLD DEAR
IN THIS WORLD IS A LIE,
ESPECIALLY ABOUT THE MIDDLE
EAST IT MAKES YOU WONDER.
WHAT IS GOING ON OVER THERE?
>> A WAVE OF CRISES
ENGULFING COUNTRIES ALL
ACROSS THE MIDDLE EAST.
>> IN THE MIDDLE EAST THINGS
ARE JUST BASICALLY FALLING
APART.
>> BIG TROUBLE IN THE
COUNTRY OF YEMEN.
>> A GROWING TERRORISM
PROBLEM IN EGYPT.
>> VERY, VERY GRUESOME AND
UGLY BATTLE OVER THERE.
>> Jon: HERE TO HELP US MAKE
SENSE OF ALL THAT IS EGYPT'S
FOREMOST POLITICAL SATIRIST HOST
OF THE NOW BANNED TELEVISION
PROGRAM AL-BERNAMEG, BASSAM
YOUSSEF.
BASSEM, THANKS FOR JOINING US.
WELCOME, SIR.
>> THANK YOU! GOOD TO BE
HERE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> Jon: BASSEM --
>> YEAH.
>> Jon: OBVIOUSLY RIGHT NOW
THE MIDDLE EAST SPIRALING
OUT OF CONTROL.
SO TELL ME, WHAT SHOULD
AMERICA DO ABOUT THIS?
>> WELL, HOW ABOUT NOTHING?
(APPLAUSE)
OH, THANK YOU.
YES, I FEEL THE LOVE, YES.
>> Jon: I -- OKAY, WE HAVEN'T
TRIED THAT ONE YET.
>> YEAH.
WE NOTICED.
HOW DO YOU THINK OUR REGON
GOT THIS WAY IN THE FIRST
PLACE?
FOR DECADES AMERICA PROPPED UP A
WHO'S WHO OF MILITARY AND
THEOCRATIC DICTATORS. THEY
GIVE YOU WHAT YOU WANTED -- OIL.
AIR FIELDS, OIL.
SECURITY ARRANGEMENTS.
OIL.
AND LET'S NOT FORGET A FEW
TORTURE BLACK SITES.
>> Jon: HEY, HEY, MRS. ROBINSON,
ARE YOU TRYING TO SEDUCE ME?
>> WE KNOW WHAT YOU ARE INTO.
MR. GREY WILL SEE YOU NOW.
AND IN RETURN, THE DICTATORS
GOT SOMEONE THEIR PEOPLE COULD
HATE INSTEAD OF THEM.
WHEN THE GARBAGE BACK HOME
DOESN'T GET PICKED UP FOR A
WEEK, WHO DO YOU
THINK PEOPLE BLAME?
>> Jon: I'M GOING TO GO WITH THE
-- THAT'S AN EASY ONE.
I'M GONNA GO WITH THE SANITATION
DEPARTMENT.
>> EXACTLY.
WE BLAME AMERICA.
SO YOU SEE, EVERYBODY GETS
WHAT THEY WANT.
IT'S A WIN, WIN, JON.
>> Jon: IT'S NOT
A WIN, WIN BASSEM.
NOT A WIN, WIN. NOT FOR THE
PEOPLE.
FOR THEM IT'S A LOSE, LOSE
AND THEN NO GARBAGE PICK UP
LOSE.
>> OH, THE PEOPLE?
YOU DON'T WANT THEM CHOOSING
THEIR OWN GOVERNMENT.
>> Jon: NO, I -- I DON'T?
>> YEAH. WHAT IF THEY ELECT
SOMEBODY AMERICA DOESN'T
WANT.
IF YOU HAD A FRIEND WHO WAS A
MANAGER AT BEST BUY BUT HE'S
ALWAYS A TOTAL ASSHOLE,
WOULD YOU WANT HIM FIRED?
>> Jon: I MEAN, IF I WOULD
LOSE MY FRIENDS AND FAMILY
DISCOUNT, THEN I-- OH.
YOU'RE SAYING THE NEXT GUY
MIGHT MAKE US PAY RETAIL.
>> YEAH, IF HE EVEN LETS YOU IN
THE STORE, JON.
>> Jon: YOU KNOW WHAT, THAT'S
OKAY.
IF THE PEOPLE CHOOSE THE
WRONG GOVERNMENT-- WE'LL
HELP THEM GET IT RIGHT AND
SEND IN A FEW TANKS, MAYBE
SOME BOOTS ON THE GROUND,
SOME ADVISORS. YOU KNOW, TO --
>> ARE YOU LISTENING TO
YOURSELF, JON?
LET IT GO.
LET IT GO ♪
♪ LET IT GO ♪
♪ SLAM THE DOOR AND-- .
>> Jon: WOW, OKAY, I THOUGHT
DRONES WERE THE WORST THING
WE EXPORTED TO THAT REGION.
>> PRINCESS. SHE'S THE DEVIL.
>> Jon: I KNOW.
>> ALRIGHT. SERIOUSLY THOUGH,
YOU CAN'T LET IT GO.
AMERICA IS LIKE A DOG WITH A
HOT SPOT ON ITS BUTT.
CALLED THE MIDDLE EAST.
AND YOU THINK YOU HAVE TO
KEEP LICKING IT BUT ARE YOU
JUST MAKING IT WORSE.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Jon: ARE YOU SAYING, ARE
YOU SAYING THAT AMERICA HAS
TO --
>> UH-HUH, YES.
>> Jon: OH, NO, NOT THE
CONE.
>> YOU NEED THE CONE, JON.
>> Jon: NOT THE CONE.
>> AMERICA NEEDS THE CONE. YES.
>> Jon: NO, NO.
WE CAN'T WEAR THE CONE.
>> YEAH.
YEAH.
>> Jon: SON OF A -- WAIT A
MINUTE, WAIT A MINUTE.
>> WHAT?
>> Jon: YOU ARE DOING IT TOO.
>> Jon: YOU ARE BLAMING AMERICA.
>> WHAT? ME?
>> Jon: YES, YOU ARE.
YOU ARE PRETENDING THAT WE'RE
RESPONSIBLE FOR ALL THE
MIDDLE EAST PROBLEMS.
>> NO.
>> Jon: ADMIT IT, THAT HOT
SPOT ON OUR BUTT WAS
FESTERING BEFORE WE EVEN
LICKED IT.
>> GROSS, EW.
>> Jon: YEAH SEE, BLAMING THE
DOG.
THE METAPHOR WAS YOURS.
LOOK, AMERICA DIDN'T CREATE ALL
THE CORRUPTION THAT CRIPPLES
MIDDLE EASTERN GOVERNMENTS.
WE DIDN'T ESTABLISH THE ENTIRE
PATRIARCHY OR THE MEDIEVAL
JUSTICE SYSTEMS.
YOU KNOW, WHAT I GOT A SONG
FOR I, BUDDY.
♪ ♪ I'M SO FANCY -- NO, THAT'S
NOT IT --
♪ ♪  WE DIDN'T START THE
FIRE BECAUSE
IT WAS ALL [BLEEP] BEFORE WE
EVEN GOT THERE.
>> LET IT GO.
>> Jon: OH, STOP.
I WILL ASK YOU ONE MORE TIME,
WHAT SHOULD AMERICA DO?
>> OKAY.
WE WANT YOU TO [BLEEP] OFF
AND LEAVE US ALONE.
>> Jon: ALL RIGHT, FINE. YOU
KNOW WHAT? FINE, FINE.
>> YEAH.
>> Jon: DONE.
BUT NOT RIGHT AWAY.
WE COULD STILL USE THE A MONEY
AND A FEW WEAPONS.
AND SOME INVESTMENTS.
WHAT I'M SAYING IS IF YOU
COULD [BLEEP] GRADUALLY OFF THAT
WOULD WORK BETTER FOR EVERYBODY.
>> Jon: BASSEM YOUSSEF,
EVERYBODY.
(APPLAUSE)